in the heart of the mississippi delta a
high school football team and its
unlikely success is captivating the
state with barely enough players to take
the field greenville christian academy
has knocked out football powerhouses and
is ranked number one in mississippi jan
crawford traveled to greenville and
discovered that a school born in an era
of hate and division is now all about
unity
here in the mississippi delta
these kids know what it's like to be
underestimated
we've always been the underdogs no one
really looked towards us
their football field is surrounded by a
soybean farm
the weight room looks like an unfinished
garage because you got big facilities
great feel great they don't matter
what they have is each other
we trust each other i trust them they
trust me i got their back they got my
back
that trust has helped these young men at
this tiny private school pull off the
impossible
greenville christian academy has run the
gauntlet against mississippi's top teams
private and public and come out number
one
they're balling they're ballroom
knocking off the top academy teams in
the state
and that's what's even more incredible
in the deep south the academy teams are
the private schools created for white
kids only
after the supreme court ordered public
schools to desegregate greenville
academy which opened in 1969 was one of
them white only
today while other academies now admit
black students greenville academy is 70
percent black it's a lot of white people
and black people coming together and we
all just know each other so we just feel
like we're at home
[Applause]
family atmosphere and christian values
are what the school strives for and the
belief that you can do great things
smith will keep it that's why star
quarterback deandre smith and others
decided last year to come to greenville
christian we bonded like a family we do
everything together smith's old school
canceled its season last year because of
covet he could have gone to fancier
private schools with better facilities
but he was drawn to the atmosphere of
greenville christian from day one i knew
it was going to be a perfect fit for me
because when i first came in
it felt like we knew each other for all
our lives dj smith hands to palmer there
was no resentment from kids already here
like senior running back marlon palmer
we all knew each other but like
come as a team it just feels like we
just reunited again and lineman wendell
poindexter who like palmer started
greenville christian in sixth grade they
helped convince smith and others to come
accepted everyone we wanted everyone to
be a part of us
just making family
the small coaching staff with this
shoestring budget all are graduates of
the school
john reed mclendon is the head coach
let's go fellas justin levy was just a
couple years behind him
jordan mcclendon is the head coach's
younger brother it's just going to show
you that you know a lot of times and you
know the nice things don't really matter
who's your strength and conditioning
coach i am okay who's your trainer
both of us who does scheduling for you
guys
i mean like
you're beating teams that have you know
a staff of like 10 people doing that and
100 kids on the field how many kids do
you guys have 35 35 36 36
these coaches say what's happening here
goes beyond football they planted the
seeds more than six years ago when they
came back and started coaching together
this school uh seems to
you know reel you in i guess just the
fact that people invested in your life
and you want to come back and invest in
other people's lives it's family it's
home just where my heart is my heart is
greenville it's the delta and it was an
opportunity for me to feel like i was
making an impact there's so many
different ways to be successful in
football football is just like an avenue
to reach other people to me honestly
because that's what i'm using it for
pretty stretch
levy was among the first black students
to enroll at greenville christian i
think we had the first group
and my friends would have decided to
come over i think it was like three or
four of us a star wide receiver in
college levy turned down an opportunity
to play in the canadian football league
choosing instead to come home this is
definitely a once in a lifetime type
thing and are you talking about the
success that you've had on the football
field the success and like how it all
happened you know
just seeing some of the kids live being
transformed i just think every kid is
here supposed to be here and god has
blessed us tremendously it's really a
blessing because
a lot of people don't have this
opportunity we have and like
we
they tell our coach tell us every day to
cherish it
[Applause]
a blessing that allows these kids to
dream of great things
i'm a kid from a small town with big
dreams like you couldn't even imagine
what i'd be thinking about so
it's crazy
[Applause]
[Music]
now deandre and four other greenville
christian players have offers to play
division one college football from
alcorn state to michigan state and
others will go on to smaller colleges
all
great things nate
jan awesome stuff sports being a
catalyst for change in a place that
definitely needs it appreciate you yeah
awesome story five d1 offers yeah that's
serious and to see the coaches come back
um after they've you know graduated but
how important it was for them to give
back to those students today and it's
one thing to have a small team but they
also have a
small
coaching staff yeah yeah three
individuals on that coaching staff and
they're the best in the state you know
i'm sure people are going to see this
hear about how they're winning and give
them some money and they're going to
have a nicer weight room but i kind of
want them to keep that old garage look
to it keep the gritty feel right yeah
it's not bad it helps make you who you
are that's for sure